[Musique]
bienvenue dans exclusif sur france24 mon
invité et raphaël grossi directeur
général de l'agencé internationale de
l'énergie atomique
bonjour merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
sur le plateau de france 24
merci merci à vous ça fait six mois que
la russie est en veille l'ukraine la
situation autour de la centrale de
zaporijia la plus grande d'europe
inquiètent particulièrement la
communauté internationale vous avez
vous-même raphaël grossi déploré de
nouveaux bombardements ces derniers
jours autour de cette centrale tout
d'abord quels sont les risques d'un
incident un accident nucléaire les
risques sont réels c'est ça la question
il ya qu'on vous dit bien c'est une
c'est une c'est une installation
important c'est la centrale nucléaire la
plus grande d'europe en europe qui est
qui est occupée par les forces russes
qui est opéré par l'opérateur nous
crânien donc déjà une situation sans
précédent et il ya eu des attaques il ya
eu des bombardements on sait qu'ils sont
justement ceux qui sont à l'origine des
attaques parce que les russes et
ukrainiens se renvoient la balle est
exactement donc il ya eu narratif qui
est contradictoire et c'est ça une lune
de choses qu'on ne devrait pouvoir
établir clairement en plus il existe la
possibilité toujours de l'interruption
de
l'approvisionnement électrique
de la centrale qui pourraient men et à
l'interruption du système de
refroidissement de la centrale
est ce que les russes justement on
ferait cela c'est à dire qu'il
interromprait éventuellement lutte elle
utilisait ce fait rente procès
d'intention tout ce que c'est le sombre
a versé 10 des organismes qui sonnera
certains craignant c'est possible on
peut pas l'exclure mais comme vous dites
bien il ya des accusations mutuelles qui
se croisent et d'ella la nécessité de la
présence de
l'inspecteur nucléaire globale qui est
l'agent ce qui est l' agence donc
l'agent ce que vous dirigez affirmé
aussi vous avez vu emmanuel macron ce
matin la france d'ailleurs soutient
cette initiative
luperto l'envoi d'une mission donc de
lagence sur place est ce qu'une telle
mission va effectivement pouvoir être
dépêchée à la page on travaille je pense
qu'il est qu'il est possible
et comme vous dites bien macron c'est
pas une question de la dernière semaine
depuis le mois de mars donc je suis en
contact avec lui il a bien compris les
enjeux
nucléaire si vous voulez des ces
conflits et mais c'est complexe il y à
il y à la question du territoire comment
on fait par où on passe donc je fais pas
c'est pas évident et la situation se
dégrader au fur et mesure de man s'est
elle dégradée bon il ya il ya les
opérations militaires se sont eux voilà
se sont aggravées
la centrale où le site devient sipa en
cible
un objet qui n'est pas épargnée par les
attaques militaires et donc c'est ce qui
est tout à fait inacceptable donc la
manière déstabiliser c'est de devenir
c'est d'avoir la présence internationale
sur place il est président macron a été
un contact avec les présidences et les
skis avec les président poutine avec moi
même on a essayé de trouver les minimes
hommes politiques pour entamer la partie
technique est ce qui est un accord
aujourd'hui entre les russes les
ukrainiens la france éventuellement et
d'autres partis pour justement l'envoi
de cette mission il ya un accord de
principe et je travaille dans le détail
le détail ça veut dire que vous avez une
date éventuellement d'un moment où
justement cette mission serait dépêché
sur place on a des hypothèses de travail
et c'est pour très vite je vous assure
très vite ça veut dire c'est les
semelles que joie non quelques jours
quelques jours donc quelques jours
effectivement une mission de l'ua pour
être dépêchée à zaporizhya qui bloque
aujourd'hui plus personne les russes je
pense que yapi yapi le blocage il y a eu
des doutes il y a eu deux je pense des
objections au niveau politique de l'un
et de l'autre côté maintenant on est
arrivé à un stade et je vais pas trop
insister là dessus histoire de n'est pas
et
donc ruiner les possibilités d'un succès
mais je crois qu'on est très très près
de l'acceptation totale et complète de
deux côtés et pourquoi est-ce qu'ils
accepteraient soudainement alors qu'il
refusait je pense que tout le monde a
compris il ya vous savez il ya quelques
jours j'ai bien fait j'ai fait un
rapport au conseil sécurité nations
unies les 15 marques plus l'ukraine et
donc il ya des différences politiques
énormes que vous pouvez bien comprendre
mais tout le monde disait une chose
l'agencé doit doit y aller tout le monde
voit que on est arrivé à un point où on
peut pas risquer en plus du drame de la
guerre un accident nucléaire donc les
russes seraient finalement convaincu de
vous laisser y aller les ukrainiens
aussi qui s'y opposait aussi au départ
oui tout le monde il était question de
persévérance et quand vous parlez de
détail comment une telle mission
peut-elle effectivement travailler dans
un pays en guerre on va donc on va
assurer moi je vais donc libérer cette
mission avec mes experts techniques donc
on fera un état des lieux si vous voulez
donc on faire à des réparations on va
rétablir des systèmes de transmission
d'informations que qui ont été
endommagées et après probablement on va
assurer une présence continue des
agences donc c'est une c'est une vaste
entreprise et espérons le une qui pourra
aider à stabiliser la situation les
ukrainiens notamment energoatom agence
qui gère lé centrale cette centrale
accusent les russes d'y stocker des
armes lourdes c'est ce qui se passe
laissez-moi y aller et on verra ce qu'on
voit mais vous avez entendu ce
commentaire de l'entente du sahara
théorique rien du ca mais on n'a pas les
moyens d corroborer sa donc l'idée c'est
d'y aller et de pouvoir le constater ou
par tafer est ce que les russes veulent
effectivement déconnecter la centrale
nucléaire du réseau électrique etc
n'aviez vers la crimée ça une autre
vient d information là dessus c'est
aussi cela ça c'est pas une chose facile
à faire vous savez c'est pas une un plat
gameplay donc c'est une grand central
pour la pour la débrancher d'un réseau
d'un guide comme on dit en anglais d'un
réseau électrique et l'arrêt connecter
un autre c'est pas une histoire de deux
jours il ya des travaux
d'infrastructures j'ai entendu ça encore
une fois c'est une de mes tâches
de quelle est elle de voir qu'est ce qui
se passe de constater et constater si
c'est vrai ou pas et ensuite une fois
qu'on constate qu est ce qui se passe
bah on fait un rapport on aura des
recommandations et offert à partie ces
recommandations conseil des gouverneurs
de l'agencé à la communauté
internationale en espérant que les
parties dans les rangs suite vous êtes
optimiste en tout cas il faut il faut
autre crise qui vous concerne
directement raphaël gros si bien sûr les
négociations autour du nucléaire iranien
alors c'est hugo session qui avait été
suspendue elles ont repris début août
les etats-unis ont indiqué que l'iran
avait fait des concessions sur un
certain nombre de points clés le
ministère iranien des affaires
étrangères a indiqué avoir reçu une
réponse des états unis est ce que
finalement on pourrait avoir un accord
au final ça à leur valeur on now now na
on a connu des moments comme ça on a
connu deux moments moins optimiste je
crois qu'on n'est pas loin c'est
maintenant à vous dites on n'est pas
allés tous les aspects techniques ont
été plus ou moins résolu c'est une
question de volonté politique de gestion
l'île depuis le début c'est une question
de volonté il y avait des problèmes
aussi au niveau technique les iraniens
en l'occurrence exigeait que léo a donc
votre agence cesse des enquêtes sur les
sites non déclaré ou il y avait des
traces d'uranium enrichi qui avaient été
retrouvés à ce qui serait revenu sur
cette condition là il y avait il y adeux
voilà des déclarations là dessus moi je
tout ce que je peux dire ces jeux
donc on sait ce pas on s'arrête pas de
travailler pour des raisons politiques
notre agence doit mener à bien son
travail et là j'ai invité et je continue
à manifester qu'on doit travailler de
manière coopérative avec l'iran afin de
clarifier ça ces choses là ne vont pas
disparaître donc il s'en venir ces
choses là les doutes kona les thèmes
qu'on doit clarifier les fêtes qu'il y a
des traces d'uranium enrichi et c'est
que vous avez cités donc les problèmes
ou
beaucoup plus que les problèmes la chose
à faire c'est dévoile à s'asseoir et
essayer sérieusement de clarifier tous
ces aspects là donc là les américains
ont l'air de dire qui on est plus proche
d'un accord aujourd'hui qu'il y a
quelques semaines donc un peu
d'optimisme je parlerai pas pour les
états unis moi je veux dire lagence elle
est là elle est prête elle pourra faire
les garanties et les inspections et cet
accord si c'est encore assez d'accord
miro possède-t-elle effectivement assez
d'uranium enrichi pour pouvoir
rapidement passer à la fabrication de la
bombe oui mais vous savez le fait
d'avoir le matériel ne veut pas dire que
vous allez directement
franchir le pas vers l'armement
nucléaire serait pas juste mais ce que
c'est le cas de le dire on n'a aucune
information qui indiquerait que l'iran à
un tel programme parce qu'il ya un
certain nombre de think tank qui le
disent
axé leur travail moi j'ai fait
l'inspection vous faites l'inspection
est ce que il ya des conditions sur
lesquelles vraiment se faire venus les
américains et les iraniens je reviens là
dessus pour justement que cet accord
soit finalement signé alors qu'il y a 2
mois franchement disait que cet accord
était caduc bon les problèmes c'est que
combres les temps passe les problèmes
s'ajoutent les les liens les
s'établissent entre des choses qui ont
qui n'ont pas qui ne sont pas
nécessairement liés aux questions
nucléaires parfois les sanctions
économiques parfois d'autres problèmes
géopolitiques et ça complique d'où
je crois l'urgence de parvenir à un
accord lorsque les conditions politiques
sont idéales et que quels sont ces
conditions politiques idéal on a vu déjà
que moi sur continue à s'opposer à cette
action c'est de se dire est ce qu'on
sera mieux avec cet accord houssin
israël pense par exemple qu'on est mieux
sans cet acord c'est l'opinion de
l'israël et les iraniens et les
américains en revanche pourrait
continuer les européens évidemment ils
sont favorables
absolument est ce que la carte
européenne justement a permis de faire
avancer ces dernières semaines les rôles
de l'europe de l'union européenne a été
crucial dans quelle mesure dans les murs
dans la mesure où comme vous savez c'est
dans cette négociation c'est l'union
européenne qui a fait la coordination
et je crois qu'ils ont fait un très bon
travail en essayant de hann est
désespérant jamais à un toujours
insistant pour arriver au moment où les
je dirais les étoiles s'admirer et les
conditions politiques serré en place
pour arriver à cet accord donc lorsqu'on
dire qu'il était caduque cet accord vous
vous pensez pas qu'il soit caduc le ce
qu'on appelle le geass ipo est non pour
l'instant nos n'a pas désespéré on à
coquilles vides et l'idée c'est de la
faire revivre telle à remplir des
contenus de faire en sorte que l'iran
commencent à observer commence à
accomplir tous les obligations qu'ils
ont laissé de de faire à cause de durée
très comme vous savez unilatérale
redonner les états unis à l'époque les
iraniens vous semble plus coopératif
aujourd'hui
ils ont dans la tente de je crois de 2,2
dès la reconduction de cet accord qui
est pour le moment dans l'impasse
merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous
rappelle grossi directeur général de
l'agencé internationale de l'énergie
atomique et merci à vous tous d'avoir
suivi cette émission exclusif rester
avec 924
[Musique]